ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนหรอสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ทุกคนก็กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนไหนวีดีโอ
บีกินเนอร์กินได้ครับนะคะอ่ะ
ก็ผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะ
ครูฟ้าล่ะคะสบายดีไหมคะครูฟาก็สบายดีค่ะ
สบายดีนักเรียนสบายดีไหมคะตายนักเรียน
สบายดีไหมนักเรียนบอกสบายดีแข็งแรง
ร้องฟังภาษาไทยแล้วขอ
ร้องฟังแล้วก็
ต้องกินอะไรค่ะ
โอเควันนี้เราค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
วันนี้วัน
จะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะอ่าวันนี้วันอังคาร
วันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
16 ค่ะเดือนอะไรเดือน
พฤศจิกายน
พฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่
เดือนที่สิบเอ็ด
ปีพต
รีโพส
มาเขียนใหญ่
[เพลง]
ปีคศราคะปีค.ศ
2002  1 ค่ะ
แบ๊บเมื่อวานวันนี้วันอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้จะมีที่เขียนเนี่ยแป๊บนึงนะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรเมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์
ค่ะถ้าวันจันทร์
[เพลง]
วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่วันจันทร์ที่
15 อ่ะเดือนอะไรเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ 11  5
ปีพตต
ปีพศ
2564 ปีคศราคะปีคศ 2  021 หางแล้วพรุ่ง
นี้วันอะไร
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธที่พรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
ก็
สวยดีค่ะ
พฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
17  57 เดือนอะไรเดือน
พฤศจิกายนตีเผาะ
[เพลง]
มีชัยค่ะ
ชาย
วันนี้นะคะครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูฟ้าจะแว็กซ์
เราจะพานักเรียนเนี่ยมารู้จักกับประเทศ
ไทยนี้โห่ประเทศไทยประเทศไทยผู้หญิงว่าน
เองมะใช่ค่ะขลุ่ยเป็นคนวาดประเทศไทยเนาะ
ทรายก็ 9 ประหารประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ไม่พร้อมกันสักอย่างประเทศไทยเราก็อันนี้
ถามหมดของประเทศไทยแต่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมัน
ก็จะแบ่ง
มันก็จะมี 1
2  3
A4
สวัสดิ์แบ่งได้ 4 ภาคใหญ่ๆ 4 ภาคไก่ค่ะ
หนึ่งเนี่ยธาตุอะไรคะครูฟ้า
1 ภาคเหนือและ
ภาคเหนือ
2 ราคะข้างอะไร
2  5 อีสานหนังภาคอีสาน 3 ภาคอะไรคะถาม
ภาคกลางค่ะแล้วสี่ล่ะคะสุดท้ายมันใหญ่ๆ
ไกลไปหน่อยผ้าอะไร 4 ภาคใต้ค่ะหรอกเขียน
ตรงนี้ละกันนี่ใช่ไหมประเทศไทยก็แบ่งได้ 4
พาทสวยมีค่าอะไรคะ
ภาคเหนือภาคอะไรคะฮะอีสาน
ภาคอะไรรูป
ภาพกลางค่ะแล้วก็สุดท้ายภาคอะไรคะฮ่าๆค่ะ
จะนะบี 4 ภาคครูฟ้า
บ้านบ้านครูฟ้า
อยู่ภาคอะไร
บ้านกูป๊าอยู่ภาคกลางค่ะ
กลาง
บ้านครูหญิงล่ะคะบ้านอยู่ภาคอะไร
บ้านครูหญิงก็เหมือนครูฟ้าอยู่ภาคกลาง
หาดแล้วนักเรียนเนาะนักเรียนที่อยู่
ประเทศไทยบ้านนักเรียนอยู่อะไรก็คอมเม้น
บอกเราได้นะ
i5 ทรายนะแต่ว่ากันอยู่
เนาะจะวันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงนะคะจะมีรูปภาพ
สมัยรูปภาพสวยๆแบบนี้
แล้วให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยดูแล้วให้สุดฟ้าคิดว่า
อยู่ภาคอะไร
เองนักเรียนอยากเล่นด้วยก็ได้นะ
นี่เพื่อนนักเรียนเคยมาประเทศธารีอะไรเลย
มาประเทศไทยและนักเรียนเข้าใจก็ภาคเหนือ
ภาคอีสานภาคกลางภาคใต้นักเรียนก็คิดได้นะ
คะคิดได้ตายอ้ะรูปที่ 1 ค่ะครูฟ้าอันนี้
เป็นน้ำตกสวยมีน้ำตกหรือต้นไม้นะคะน้ำตก
หรอนั้นตกอันนี้นะคะชื่อว่าน้ำตกคลองร้าน
นี้มี
สระน้ำตกคลองลานครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดว่าน้ำตก
คลองลาน
อยู่
ถ้าอะไร
ลูกเหลือทั้งนี้ศาลพระกลางหรือว่าถ้าใต้
รูปอาร์ตคิดว่า
คิดว่าน้ำตกคลองลานอยู่ภาคกลางค่ะโทรฟ้า
คิดภาคกลาง
พรรค
[เพลง]
ถูกฆ่า
น้ำตกคลองร้านอยู่ภาคกลางเก่งมากเก่งมาก
ครูฟ้า
ดีเลย์บ้าง
รูปต่อไปค่ะรูปต่อใบหา OK มีรูปต่อไปอีก
ชื่ออัมรูปต่อไปเป็น
ดอกไม้สวยไหมดอกไม้
ดอกไม้อันนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าว่าดอกกล้วย
ไม้
ดอกกล้วยไม้
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีชื่อเสียงดูใกล้ๆเนาะดอก
กล้วยไม้นะเว้ยสาเหตุหรือเปล่าเห็นอะไร
ยังไม่เห็นยังไม่เห็นอ่ะต่อกล้วยไม้นะคะ
อันนี้ได้มันชื่อว่าเป็นที่ที่มีดอกกล้วย
ไม้เยอะมากๆ
เนาะครูฟ้าคิดว่าที่นี่นะคะที่เราเนี่ยจะ
ไปดูดอกกล้วยไม้เนี่ยอยู่ธาตุอะไรอยู่ภาค
อะไร
ภาคเหนือภาคอีสานภาคกลางหรือว่าภาคใต้
ดอกกล้วยไม้หรอหาน้านและภาคเหนือ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าภาคเหนือใช่ไหม
เหนือ
ผิดค่ะค่ะ
ไม่ใช่ภาคเหนือ
ให้ภาคเหนือผู้หญิงให้ครูฟ้าตอบอีก 1
ครั้งทำไมข้างเหนือเนี่ยไม่ใช่เหลือภาค
อีสานภาคกลางแล้วก็ภาคใต้ครูฟ้าคิดว่าท่า
อะไร
ท่ากลางค่ากลาง
ผิดฆ่าไอ้ใส่ปากกลางอ่ะสิบห้าสิบแล้ว
เหลือ 2 ธาตุภาคอีสานกับภาคใต้
ฟ้าคิดว่าค่ากะไรดอก
ขอให้ไม้ภาพ
ใต้ๆ
พันธุ์อีสานค่ะใจไปหลายๆ
ไม่เก่งเลยค่ะนี่นะภาคอีสานเนาะเออดอกเลย
หมายบางทีสายฟ้าจะไม่ชอบดอกไม้เอา
ลองมาดูกันบ้างหรออันนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่า
ปราสาทหินใช่ไหมคะทั้งหมดเลยเนาะเป็น
ปราสาทหินหลังทำมาจากหินนะคะปราสาทหินอะ
นี้ชื่อปราสาทเมืองต่ำ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าปราสาทเมืองต่ำเนี่ยนะคะอยู่
ค่าอะไรค่าเหลือภาคหน้าศาลถ้ากลางหรือว่า
ธาตุๆ
โอ้ว
ปราสาทเมืองต่ำอยู่อยู่ภาคอีสานหะ
รูฟ้าตอบว่าภาคอีสาน
ถูกต้องค่ะค่า
[เพลง]
จะมีพระนอนนะคะอยู่ภาคอะไร
ภาคเหนือภาคอีสานภาคกลางหรือว่าภาคใต้
วัดโพธิ์อยู่อ้ากลางค่ะครูบาสตอบว่าถ้า
กลาง
ถูกฟ้า
ถูกฆ่า
เก่งมาก
อะไรจะเห็นนี่เป็นอันนี้คือวัดโพธิ์
แล้วก็มี
พระนอนนะครับนอนเก่งมากๆต่อไปค่ะอันนี้
เป็นรูปที่ครูฟ้าเห็นเนาะใช่ไหมอันนี้
เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าอันนี้เป็นรถไฟบ่อปูนปูน
รถไฟหนอนี้เป็นทางรถไฟแล้วก็มีที่เก็บน้ำ
ให้เป็นน้ำน้ำนะคะทางรถไฟอันนี้เนี่ยชื่อ
ว่า
ทางรถไฟเขื่อนป่าสัก
หรอตรงนี้นะคะอ่ะครูฟ้าคิว่าอยู่ค่ากะไร
ภาคเหนือภาคอีสานภาคกลางหรือว่าธาตุใต้
คู่ฟ้าคิดว่าอยู่ภาคเหนือค่ะลูกสาวบอก
เหนือ
ผิดค่ะ
ผิดค่ะไม่ใช่คาดเหนือ
เหลือภาคอีสานภาคกลางแล้วก็ภาคใต้โครงฟ้า
คิดว่ามีภาพอะไร
ฟ้าคือได้ยินนะลืมอะ 5 กลาง
ครูฟ้าบอกว่าถ้ากลาง
ถูกฆ่าถ้าแยกเหตุน้องชายเขาก็บอกว่าอัน
นี้นะคะถ้านักเรียนมั่งนั่งรถไฟนั่งรถไฟ
อันนี้นะ
ใช่ก็จะนักเรียนก็จะได้ดูวิวใช่ไหมข้าง
ซ้ายข้างขวาสวยมาก
นั่งเหล็กไฟดอกไปค่ะอันนี้นะ
อันนี้เนี่ยเป็นภูเขาแล้วก็ทะเลหรอทะเล
อันนี้ชื่อว่าภูเขาตาม่องลายนะคะทั้งหมด
นี้นะครูฟ้าคิดว่าภูเขาตาม่องล่าขอให้
อยู่ภาคอะไร
ภาคเหนือภาคอีสานภาคกลางหรือว่าภาคใต้
ฝ้าคิดว่ากูเขาตาม่องลายอยู่ภาคใต้ค่ะภาค
ใต้ใช่ไหมคะ
ผิดค่ะไม่ใช่ภาคใต้ถ้างั้นอยู่ภาคอีสาน
อีสานไม่มีทะเลทะเลมันมีทะเลทะเลนี่คือ
ทะเลทะเลค่ะลืมทักวางอะภาคกลาง
ครูฟ้าบอกว่าถ้ากลางที่ถูกฆ่า
เย้
ต่ายทู้เขาตาม่องลายนะอยู่หมู่บ้านกลาง
Kitty หญิงที่เรียกภูเขาว่ะก็คือภาคกลาง
นะคะไม่เห็น
เขา
มีอีกหนึ่งที่นะฮะได้อีกหนึ่งพี่นะคะก็
คืออันนี้เนี่ยเป็นเหมือนอควาเรียมนะ
มังกรเลี่ยมนี่จะไม่ไปเอาข้อเรียกวันนี้
เนี่ยมีปลานักเรียนเห็นปลาใช่ไหมคะอันนี้
หน้าเป็นแม่น้ำนะไม่ใช่ทะเล
อันนี้เป็นทะเลใช่ไหมทะเลเนาะทะเลก็จะมี
อควาเรียมจะว่าเอาข้อเรียงอันนี้เนี่ยไม่
ใช่ทะเลเป็นแม่น้ำ
ชื่อว่า
บึงฉวากณบึงฉวาก
บึงฉวากงอ่ะดึงฉวาดอควาเรียมเนี่ยครูแม่
ค้าคิดว่า
อยู่ภาพอะไรเหนือภาคอีสานภาคกลางหรือว่า
ภาคใต้
บึงทองว่าค่ะชาย
สร้างค่ะครูฟ้าบอกว่า
อีสาน
ใช่มั้ยฮะอีสาน
ครูฟ้าเขตภาคอีสานใช่ไหมคะมึงไสวน้า
ผิดค่ะไม่ใช่ภาคอีสานภาคใต้
ถ้าใต้
ผิดค่ะไม่ใช่ภาคใต้ภาคกลางอ่ะ
เหลือถ้ากลางกับข้างเหลือน้อยครูฟ้าจัง
เลยคิดภาคกลาง
ถูกต้องค่ะ
ภาษาทางเยอะก็
แย่
หมดแล้วหรือยังคะหรือว่าจะล็อคน่าจะน่าจะ
ได้ดูอีกอันนึงแล้วกันอะอย่างเนียนเป็น
อันนึงแล้วกันเนาะครูใจดีนะคะ
อันนี้แล้วกันเนาะอันนี้เนี่ยะให้นัก
เรียนอันนี้ไปดูปลานี้เป็นปลาโลมางั้นจะ
เป็นวันปลาโลมา
เป็นอย่างนี้ใช่ไหมปลาโลมา
ที่น่าปลาโลมา
อ่าไปดูปลาโลมาเนี่ยนะคะอันนี้เนี่ยอยู่
ถ้าอะไร
เหนืออีสานกลางหรือว่าภาคใต้
ปลาโลมา
เอาปลาโลมา
ธาตุอะไร
ภาคกลางค่ะภาคกลาง
[เพลง]
เก่งมาก
เอาถูกต้องใช่มั้ย
เธอคือฟ้าใกล้ๆบ้านครูฟ้าใกล้ๆพัทยาไปดู
ได้เนาะปลาโลมาสวยวันนี้เนี่ยนะกูหญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าและก็พานักเรียนมารู้จักที่เที่ยว
ในประเทศไทย 4 ภาคสมัยคะอันนี้มีฮะอะไร
บ้างครูฟ้าภาคอะไรคะมีพักเหนือ
ภาคอีสาน
ภาคกลาง
ภาพๆค่ะค่ะใช่ถ้านักเรียนเนาะเคยไปดูที่
ไหนในภาคไหนคะก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะ
วันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนใช่ไหมคะอ่าก่อนไป
ก็อย่าลืมทำอะไรคะ
อย่าลืมกด like กด Share กด Subscribe
ด้วยนะคะนักเรียนคนใดหาแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้าเนาะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ